hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and welcome to the end of the week it is
Friday January 20th 2023 and you know
Market is sort of back up uh close to uh
the 4 000 area we closed around 39.87 we
have a beautiful rally
um you know basically from around uh you
know just after the cash opened
pretty much the rest of the day now you
know going coming into the cash session
it was pretty pretty quiet I mean pretty
awesome by most standards
um we did have a high during the
European session and sold off down to uh
some nice new lows but we're still you
know in you know a fairly tight range
you know 32 and three quarters down to
um you know around 12. so you know about
a 30 uh sorry the 20 point range so it's
pretty quiet most of the night but then
it once cash opened up we sort of sold
off and started testing the lows didn't
quite take it out and then we just put
in a nice rally to close out the week
you know if you can sort of go back uh
to you know the other day we're trading
you know in for around the 4000 area now
let's take a look at some of the order
flow now
you know the thing with uh with order
flow all right and people call order
flow reading the tape Etc you know
really what order flow allows you to do
is to see
um the market moving forces in action
right and sort of prevail judge which
one is prevailing at the moment okay we
are basically taking
the information as it's being generated
and using it to our advantage and you
know since it's Friday I'll sort of
recap some of the things that I've been
talking about during the week so that
you could see them in action okay so
like I said cash opened and we promptly
started selling off towards our low of
the day low was uh 11 and three quarters
we got all the way down to 12 and a
quarter okay now if you remember
yesterday I did a video about those
abandoned value areas those value areas
that
the next bar doesn't retrace back into
it's often a sign of a market starting
to pick up momentum and move
okay so what happens literally as we
test that low we get one of those bars
what happens the market proceeds to not
retrace back into it in the next bar
angle is higher next bar higher higher
higher and we trade all the way up to
the high of the day literally
within you know this was about 8 39 so
this bar afterwards was 8 40. you know
this is right around the 3920 area we
rally all the way up to
um the high which was uh 33 and started
making new highs get all the way up to
37 before we pull back a bit and as we
pull back we see another
abandoned value area coming in here
right around this 3930 area right the
next bar trades back within one tick of
the high of that value area
then X bar goes higher so you know it's
trading 39.34 does pull back again with
the 31 and a quarter the high is um
what is this price here 31 so we get
back within you know about a tick
and then we rally up to new highs again
okay and then what do we see we start
seeing you know some more right we see
another bullish one in here does pull
back it's two ticks through it and
starts going back up making new highs
and you know we just sort of see that
repeating
during the course of the trading day now
there were some shorts in here like this
was a short which you know came right
back in and then two bars later he was
another short
um he started to make a move then it
came back up tested it literally right
you know one tick into it two ticks into
it
and has a little bit of a sell-off
tested again sells off now here we got
you know a little bit of a Down move we
got a nice abandoned bearish value area
here right so you're getting short
somewhere around the 50 Area somewhere
in here 49 and a half 50. you get
another one right in you know right
after that
so imagine you know you get short there
on the 3950 area and within a few bars
it trades all the way down into the 40s
and then you know a little bit of back
and forth action here there was a
bullish one here started to go up and
then just sort of went sideways and you
get a bearish one bearish one
um you know a little sideways and we
start making new highs you know bullish
one here
you know this is the bearish one here
which you know small move
um and higher and higher up here this is
a ratio and Divergence which is actually
a bearish signal this one came in around
134 just started coming off went
sideways
um before eventually starting to Rally
back up okay so that was just you know
sort of recapping that
um you know trading strategy around
abandoned value areas again some people
will call them you know naked value
areas or virgin value areas
um you know sort of the idea is you know
when you're looking at them with Market
profile or volume profile it's poor
structure and you're sort of waiting for
the market eventually to come back to it
I like to just trade it just go with the
trades you know it's just it's just
great opportunity to catch
um you know some of those
nice moves now again you know you saw
that one coming in there just
around except the cache open here so 839
or something right or coming in right
here at
right above the low of the day you know
which is literally
right here now I'm not saying oh yeah
it's a beautiful trade you could cut
that whole thing up
um no you know you could have caught at
least the move back up to the highs
maybe into the new highs
because obviously there's more things
what can you have seen in the order flow
to catch more of this nice monster move
up well earlier in the week I talked
about this as well all right the failed
divergences right understanding when a
market is in a flow driven Market when a
market is in a flow driven Market take
out all your technical indicators throw
them out the window and you know the
thing with technical indicators right
there's plenty of them and Traders use
them in all sorts of different
combinations and many of them are
they're very sophisticated and you know
with computers it's very easy to watch
it in real time you know imagine if you
were trading back in the 80s you know
when home computers were just getting
popular you know people you had their
old you know the IBM or even the Apple
2E you know doing their charts for them
you know before everyone's doing them by
hand I remember in the gosh when was it
in the early 90s I remember taking a
course at the CME and the guy there Ken
Chalino a great Trader
Bond guy he's still keeping charts by
hand all right and if I don't know if
you know most of my followers here
aren't really Old-Timers they're new but
they used to you know you used to get
the chart book each week you know sort
of like this oversized
thing in the mail you know think of
Baron's news oh the parents publishes
but it was a big thing and you know you
get all the commodity charts all the
Futures charts and you just update it by
hand during the week
now
foreign
order flow in my opinion is
one of those things that's truly
Universal that can be combined with any
technical study right and you know I
often suggest it as a base for any other
method that Traders are using now the
thing with
indicators right and you know I release
indicators I release orderful based
indicators which basically analyzes the
order flow to you as opposed to just
analyzing prices
um
most price-based indicators are based on
these fancy I'll say fancy but
complicated calculations and they
somewhat mask the reality of a scenario
that's happening right because it's just
looking at Price whereas you know
looking at the order flow you understand
sort of the the
intensity of a move if you will all
right so it's just one of those things
where you know just like we saw the
other day
um
you know when there's actually bullish
information out in the market and the
market is selling off right I mean all
the technical indicators say oh it's
bullish but the market keeps selling off
if you're looking at the order flow
you're taking advantage of what is
happening right now right not
um you know well I got to keep buying it
because this says is bullish so I gotta
buy it well no if you see the aggression
taking place in the market then you know
you're probably going to want to keep
going with the trade
so flow driven markets okay
one of the signs of a flow driven market
is when you have bearish information in
the order flow
well for a flow driven Market to the
upside when you have you know bearish
information coming in at highs of the
day
and you keep making new highs okay at
some point
you gotta you know let's take the
the line out of the great movie The
Magnificent Seven the original one in
the 60s
not the one that came out a few years
ago yeah sometimes you gotta turn Mama's
picture to the wall and get out
if you're trying to short every time you
have a new high with selling right a
Delta Divergence meaning a new high with
negative Delta negative Delta tells you
there's aggressive selling coming into
the market yeah sure you can make some
money sometime but when you have these
things failing repeatedly that should be
your clue that hey you know what there's
probably bigger forces that Mark in the
market and what I mean by bigger forces
is the other time frame Traders the
smart money all right the guys with
Deep Pockets that are are buying and
holding for a longer period of time than
you or me obviously much longer than
today you know probably holding it for
weeks months even so at 9 10 we see our
first sign here okay we have Divergence
right we've got negative Delta at the
high of the day Market does pull back a
little bit from you know 37 and a
quarter down to you know the 28th area
here and then we come back up make a new
High pretty quick okay we don't have a
Divergence here all right then again
another one coming in here at 1004.
okay so you know our first one came back
you know 9 10 1004 so about an hour
later you get another one this time
the market pulls back
it only pulls back a couple of ticks one
tick below the low of the bar that you
had the initial selling right and then
it pulls back a few bars later after you
make a new high
another tick okay so in the first time
you hit that high here right we pulled
back you know about seven or eight
points now you're pulling back
one to two ticks okay so Divergence have
failed another Divergence that failed
Maybe
we just may be looking at a flow driven
Market okay then here we get another one
10 21.
some selling coming in
this time Market pulls back pulls back
about one point
you know a couple one two three four
five okay six takes a point and a half
now we're looking here at 39.48 okay the
first pullback was seven or eight points
second pullback was two ticks third
pullback is six ticks and I'm not
talking points on these last two
pullbacks first pullback so I was
talking in points
eight points
now it's pulling back in ticks
all right so it's pulling back a lot
less
that should be assigned to you that hey
you know what there's a lot of buying
taking place in this market
so you know here at this high
right here you just draw the line 39.49
okay if we break that you want to be
long period okay
pull up the chart here 39.49 all right
this is the break right here right here
just draw this line
right there you could break that
it's Off to the Races we do we break it
see on the footprint here we break it
immediately
get another couple divergences okay then
you know maybe people will say Mike you
know the first Divergence came in around
nine you know 9 10 second one came in at
1004 this other one came in here at 10
21. that's very spread out you know
because I I prefer it to be within about
an hour this one's a little bit outside
that window it's about an hour and 15
minutes okay you don't have to take it
or you don't have to sit there it's not
set in stone that it has to be
exactly
one hour right I if I can get in 30
minutes fantastic
but okay fine let's see okay this one
comes in at 10 20. here this one 1004
okay so let's look at this let's forget
about the first one that came in at 905
and then we'll take this more recent one
10 21 and then up here
got this nice little double top going on
here
39.54 this High you've got a couple
divergences now we pull back this time
we pull back from you know 54 down to 45
46 sort of goes sideways a bit for a
little bit of a while but all you got to
do is you just you just drop in your buy
stop up here you know one tick Above
This high at 54.
and a quarter right here because I
believe it's 54 or 54 and a quarter so
you just drop it in okay let's call four
and a half
okay and you just wait you just leave it
there
waiting for that buying pressure to
still come in and move the market higher
it gets up here again almost just hits
it you know gets within
um less than a point
and then it drops down or drops back
down to you know what was that 42 and a
quarter
all right rallies up drops back a little
bit more 40 and a quarter okay lo and
behold finally comes back up to 54 and
three quarters once it hits 54 and three
quarters
it's
up up 54 and three quarters
where's that right here
this time
you got no pullback you don't take any
heat down this trade this is you know
basically it will just make it easier
for the math part let's call it 55.
right here 55
all the way up to into the 80s I don't
say oh yeah you got out there I mean
this is 65 75
you know selling into a rising market
like that it's very easy to get out
um you know but you know realistically
you could have got out you know maybe on
this pullback here around 70. it's a
nice 15 points
so you know when I was when I first
started trading I had my method of
trading range breakouts
around the open and sometimes I
so I'll say naive but uh
I sort of had this thing where you know
I'd be getting in if I could get in as
early as possible
my goal was to hold that as long as
possible and people like why are you
what's your profit Target
even though I get out Moc Market on
clothes it was essentially uh infinity
but
um yeah that was the very very early
days of my trading career but um you
know I was felt it was better to try and
hold the trade as long as you can
um that was before I became enlightened
into an understanding order flow
that was a long time ago it's back in
the 90s anyway I hope uh you guys found
this video useful and understanding of
flow driven Market understand you start
putting pieces together right it was a
nice day to wrap up some of the things
that I taught earlier in the week with
the value areas as well as recognizing a
trend date yeah I you know wish it was
something so obvious and clear that you
could have just bought it here and hold
it for the rest of the day but there was
a sign to buy down here in the order
flow right to catch some of this move up
then as you're making these new highs
again there was another sign in the
order flow that is telling you that you
know what there's Major Market players
in the market here getting involved and
when you see Major Market players get
involved you better get involved in the
same direction that they're going
because
you know you're not trying to lead them
you're just joining them right you're
the Sixth Man on the bench you're the
seventh man on the depth chart
you know you still get at the end of the
year you still get a you still get a
ring when you win the Championships so
just go with them
all right so anyway guys
have a great weekend and I'll catch you
on the next video bye-bye